hey what's up Samuel leaves here and in
this video I wanted to explain to you
how you can profit from serviced
accommodation in property in the UK so
what is the service accommodation
service accommodation is basically a
hotel it's when you rent out a property
or a room and you rent it out just like
a hotel so it will be on booking.com
when people search for hotels in
such-and-such an area your property will
come up as a hotel how do you get into
that business and how do you do that
well you can rent out a property as a
hotel you don't need a license
there's no legislations around it you
can literally your house that you live
in you could put that list it as a hotel
on booking.com
and all the different sites which is
kind of incredible what is it incredible
it's incredible because your house might
rent out four five hundred pounds a
month a thousand pounds a month two
thousand pounds a month whatever that's
per month but on as a hotel your house
might rent out 200 300 500 pounds per
night per night so so it's almost like
HMOs you can rent out a property as a
single that that you can make money and
you can be okay and you have to have
quite a lot of houses to make good cash
flow that's option one option two is
HMOs where you can buy a house split it
up rent out room by room with fixed
tenants but renting out as a hotel like
geez that's surely that could be very
profitable and the answer is yes it can
and also many people are doing this in
the UK so there are of course things to
consider I don't want you tonight to put
your healthy to move out of your house
and to put your house on booking.com
and rinse out as a hotel because there
are things you need to consider but when
you do the right market research and I
said there's no legislation there is no
legislation in the sense of your house
will qualify even HMO HMO has to be
certain room sizes you need to have fire
dogs in to have smoke alarms you to a
licensed but with a serviced
accommodation I
you don't need a license will that
change maybe what's the case right now
you can do it
of course there are things you need to
look for I've done a little video if you
just see above the things that you need
to make sure rules wise amigos to the
mortgage and stuff that you need to look
for now how does this affect you right
now well what it means is it just means
that if you've got a limited funds let's
say you've got fifty thousand pounds or
twenty thousand pounds it means that
rather than buying your property to put
a tenant in it means that you can buy a
property whether that be an apartment a
house whatever you can buy property with
the sole purpose of renting this
property out as a hotel which means that
instead of getting a ten or even a
twenty percent return on investment you
could be making a fifty you could be
making a hundred or two hundred percent
return on investment so that's the first
thing which is crazy incredible
ridiculous right the second thing is if
you haven't got any money you can do
rent to serviced accommodation so you
can still benefit from this by renting
your property off a landlord and then
getting his permission to be able to use
this as a service dicamba Dacian
property now we've got properties in
Birmingham we've got properties that
were renting out for 700 pounds a month
just apartments in Birmingham and now
we're renting them out as a hotel we're
now getting 150 pounds per night
so we've like quadrupled a profit from
this property by using serviced
accommodation now how on earth do you
run it as a hotel does that mean you
need to employ a hotel manager you need
to have a chef in there you have a
restaurant in there absolutely not you
might be non the receiving end you may
have been a customer into one of these
properties and here's what happens you
have no staff you have just simply a key
safe outside the property so when the
guests arrive to check in they'll let
themself in this is all done systemized
automatically so you get the same kind
of money as the hotels but actually
you're just an investor and hotels
probably hate this probably the big boy
chip hotel chains probably hate people
doing this because we're messing with
their business but we're getting the
massive income like hotels are without
having to own hotels without having to
employ staff like hotels this is a
strategy for the
you know we've had people come to our
property investors crash-course who are
refugees who have no money who have bad
credit who haven't even got a property
portfolio they're just starting out and
they go straight into serviced
accommodation and they're killing it
they're killing it so this strategy is
definitely something that can be applied
for the little guys as well as the big
guys think you need to watch for is this
is a business so this isn't printing
money this isn't you know it's not
something like some magic wand and you
waive the service accommodation wand
over it and it's everything suddenly
becomes great and you become wealthy no
this is a business so you need to do
your market research you need to make
sure that if you're taking on apartments
buying properties if you're trying to
rent your own property out like this you
need to make sure that the market is
ripe and ready for this because it
doesn't work everywhere it just works in
certain areas this can be a strategy
that's being worked with used in America
this is being used all over the world if
England UK Europe but you need to do
your market research in an area how do
you do that what I would suggest is find
out what the hotels are doing you
wouldn't buy a hotel having done no
market research you check the demand and
then you'd buy the hotel and in the same
way well then you're not going to be
losing as much money up front than if
you bought a hotel for the little guy
just doing a rent to rent he's only
putting out three thousand pounds to
control a property but that's still
three thousand pounds of salt and money
to some people so do your market
research make sure that it would work
well and you would have guests there
next if you're running your properties
of serviced accommodation be a proud
property owner or landlord or control or
whatever make sure that when the your
guests come in it is immaculate it is
mint you know make sure that you have
cleaners going in and out make sure that
your systems work well so it's very
doable it's very possible but get the
right train and get the right knowledge
so that's a little bit of an overview
from me about service de Commendation
I'm getting a lot of requests to talk
about this I'm reluctant to talk about
it because I think that what's happening
is people are doing it because I'm
talking about it because they see me
doing it but then they're doing it wrong
and then they're giving people like me a
bad rep so just make sure you get the
training just make sure you do it
properly but yes you can get very very
wealthy and financially free very very
fast by properly getting the right
training and applying serviced
accommodation to your strategy
the help thank you so much for watching
do subscribe share the video so other
people know what's going on enlighten
them as well and hit the notification
bow I look forward to seeing you next
time thank you so much
thank you so much for watching this
video it's mentoring on a Monday every
single week at 7 p.m. on a Monday
between 8 p.m. I'm gonna be live
answering all your comments and
questions don't forget to subscribe
right over here so you'll never miss one
of these videos I'll see you next week
at 7 p.m.
also if you haven't got a copy of my
book you need this in your life
you can get it from Amazon for ten pound
ninety nine or a gift from made
absolutely free down below in the
description link I'll see you next week
monday at 7 p.m.